well believe it or not the full release
of all files related to the JFK
assassination has been delayed yet again
this time until 2021
president delayed the release in the
name of national security but it raises
the question what possible national
security interest could be served at
this point in protecting information
about an assassination that occurred
fifty five years ago Robert F Kennedy
jr. is the author of American values he
is of course the nephew of the slain
president he joins us tonight it's such
an odd I've never done a segment on the
assassination before but I'm so struck
by how weird this story is the president
has said point blank couple of times I'm
gonna release all these files he was
convinced for some reason not to release
them what do you imagine that reason
really was well I share your
mystification and the you know with the
stuff that's dribbling out it is
information that tends to I mean the
last one that was the mayor of Dallas my
uncle is assassinated was actually some
information about the automobile that
show that the window had been replaced
any information that 50 years later
people should know about people should
have access to that kind of information
and it's kind of do you believe that the
CIA or another government agency was in
any way involved in the assassination of
your uncle I don't know I don't think
that that possibility has been
eliminated a lot of people don't
understand that
and John Kennedy was killed my father
really laws it was Attorney General and
so one of the defenses of the Warren
Commission was well Bobby Kennedy was
the best investigator of that era he was
like Muller of a tear right you know we
have been for ten years investigating
the Teamsters yeah and the mob and so
why wouldn't he investigate him but the
truth is that David his brother was
killed he lost all of the investigative
capacity in the Department of Justice
30,000 FBI agents who worked for him but
he never talked to worry yeah not a
single time after my uncle Jack was
killed he really had no you know who
were at that time began reporting
directly to Johnson and my father who
used who was Austin's oblique worse boss
really lost control of the FBI an
investigative capacity of the department
he resigns and afterward I just find the
whole thing remarkable with the Attorney
General the United States later a US
senator a person in position to have a
lot of information would suspect his own
CIA and now the documents are still
being withheld by that same agency I
think it's really fascinating the book
is American values Robert F Kennedy jr.
it is out and I we urge you to check it
out Bobby Kennedy thanks very much for
that I appreciate it